hey what's up guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my game and in series
sir
last time we took a look at the whole
context think reading a graphics context
specifically in urk and shale so that we
can actually do some rendering and we we
kind of explored how it will be
different across all different rendering
api's definitely check out that latest
video if you haven't already and today
what we're gonna do is kind of this is
gonna go kind of gonna be an intro to
the next few episodes so the next few
episodes over the next few episodes were
going to be building up some sort of
rendering API I was originally going to
do some kind of actual renderer class
but I don't think that's quite necessary
now it's kind of gonna be a boring
episode as well I didn't really want to
do that we haven't but kind a lot like
last time we kind of almost had this
glimpse of HAARP that we're gonna render
this triangle and we never kind of got
there and I've been kind of feeling
about a week to be honest so what we're
gonna do today is actually render a
trying on the screen not using GL begin
a deal and don't worry we're gonna do it
properly and then from there like the
reason I kind of thought that would be a
good idea to doing this kind of episode
is because that's gonna kind of lay the
foundation of what we're gonna do the
next few episodes so that you guys who
aren't kind of familiar with graphics
already will have a little bit more
context see what I did there graphics
context laid like last video watch that
anyway you would have a little bit more
context as to why we're going to be
creating the classes kind of for various
kind of rendering primitives like vertex
buff is the index buffers vertex arrays
you know it's the shaders textures that
kind of stuff because that's where this
is heading right we need to build up
some kind of API and then next week oh
I've got quite the video for you guys
next week you gotta hang on there but
next week we're actually going to be
taking things a little bit we're gonna
make things more exciting and have a
more exciting goal to actually work
towards that's kind of the idea I
thought that maybe we could build
something really simple in this episode
just kind of straight like kind of raw
OpenGL calls running out right in our
application
glass to show everything that we need to
then take and move and abstract into
kind of classes so that that way instead
of just spending three episodes building
classes and not even having a triangle
and then only having it come together in
the end we kind of have it immediately
and then we kind of sort everything out
as we go
before we jump in I just want to take
this moment to thank all the patrons
from ABC as possible patreon icon for
sash the Turner
great place to actually support this
series you get many benefits such as
videos early I think the videos early
things probably gonna resume next week
because I'm still kind of recovering
from my honeymoon and by recovering I
mean I'm still kind of trying to like
sort everything out I mean I've just
moved into my kind of renovated
apartment and all that stuff and so
because of that I need to kind of soak
enough sorting everything out with work
as well and there's so much stuff going
on but next week I think that should be
back and then we'll so you'll get access
to the hazel development branch which is
like kind of my private dev branch where
I just push code like pretty pretty
often and that's kind of where you'll
see this engine a lot more advanced for
things like Brenda command keys and all
that stuff already kind of implement it
and in fact because a lot of the stuff
on that development branch is actually a
lot more advanced some of that stuff
won't make it into the series for like
months if not like a year maybe because
we've got so much more to cover like
it's almost like the hazel dev branch is
me just having fun playing around with
different development kind of ideas and
actually just jamming and everything as
I would as a software engineer whereas
this is more of like an educational
series that kind of goes a little bit of
a different direction obviously in the
end they should be identical but it's
like the parts are very different so
definitely check that out if you're
interested all right back to this so
that that's kind of what we're gonna do
I'm just gonna jump in right some OpenGL
card off the top of my head to be honest
got no reference at all but I'm pretty
good with OpenGL so hopefully we'll get
a triangle up and running in kind of a
dodgy way that may not work on all
graphics drivers that's how you know
this we
gonna be exciting but hopefully like I
really really interesting you guys to
actually try this out and see if it
works and let me know in the comments
below anyway let's just jump in and take
a look at what we have here all right so
this is hazel well game engine we can
working on if I just launch it you'll
see we have kind of this pink this kind
of pink clear color here that's the
first thing I kind of want to change
let's make that maybe black because um
or in fact and that's why by the way but
let's make it maybe like 0.2 or
something like that like really kind of
dark grey it's probably not that dog
just so that we can have something a
little bit darker because that Pink's
beginning to annoy me yeah something
like that maybe even 0.1 I'm gonna waste
too much time on this but I do want
something fairly dark and then so this
just kind of will make this a little bit
more bearable I think there we go that's
pretty good
and now what I want to do is kind of
draw a triangle in the middle so if we
kind of move this I'm GUI demo out of
the way I just want a triangle kind of
in the middle here right and so to do
that what I actually need if you think
about OpenGL and think about what we
actually need this is by the way is a
great time for you guys to actually
check out the OpenGL series I have it
some time like playlist of videos it's
called the open shell series it's where
I actually teach kind of OpenGL by
itself not necessarily in a game engine
which is how to actually use up in jail
to render graphics by the way that
series I know I haven't uploaded a video
in so long but I'm about to jump back on
that train since we are actually doing
rendering stuff in hazel now so that
video that don't think of that series
like oh yeah watch you know that was a
thing of the past and now hazel is
taking your nor that series still as a
standalone good series where I actually
explained how rendering and how OpenGL
works so definitely check it out because
that will help help clear this up what
I'm about to explain now there's a bit
there's gonna be a bit of overlap
between the series I'm not gonna dive in
too deeply into graphics in this series
specifically just because of course this
is about
and general Gammage not necessarily
graphics series although I can't just
talk about rendering your knowledge to
talk about it but what I'm saying is
that um a lot of these things if you're
not very familiar with graphics and you
want more information and you want to
even maybe start writing your own card
for this outside of just waiting for
these episodes to come out every week
you have to check out that series
because it's just there's so much good
stuff in there and I'm gonna keep adding
to it very soon alright anyway so what
you would already know is that there's
make component sky rendering a triangle
right I mean we essentially need those
you can't drop these down so we
essentially need something called a
vertex array it's required for core for
the core up in jail profile Formica
version 3.0 hi I'm not sure um we need
something called a vertex buffer we need
something called any index buffer we
need something called a shader I think
that's probably about it to be honest
these are kind of the three things that
we out of the four things that we
absolutely need right but what we can
actually do is um because if you think
about the amount of code we need to
write all these this is these three not
much this a lot right we need to write a
vertex shader and a fragment shader and
all the courage to actually compile that
shader that's a lot of work don't really
want to do that right now
okay we actually don't need that because
GPU drivers typically supply kind of a
default shader that they will actually
activate if you haven't done anything at
all so I'm not not every graphics driver
will do this but a lot of them will and
in fact I'm on this laptop right here
and that's got both an NVIDIA GPU and an
Intel GPA and they both seem to actually
supply these so definitely at the end of
this video try out try out this code I'm
gonna give you and the code that I'm
going to write here you can even just
clone the hazel repository and see for
yourself I'm gonna just let me know what
kind of what GPU you're running and if
it worked or not we might have input
some code in to actually get the actual
GPU vendor out so that we can check that
all right anyway um vertex array
vertex buffer index buffer those are the
three things that we need to create in
order to actually get a triangle
rendering on the screen we don't need
any shaders we don't need any maths but
this is this combo we need so let's just
get started what I'll do is I'll go to
application file here and I'm gonna
create basically three unsigned integers
because they're gonna be the IDS right
so we're gonna have our vertex array our
vertex buffer and our index buffer
alright let me just move this out of the
way and then what I'm gonna do is over
here just gonna create all them so we'll
get rid of this this is the constructor
for application by the way I'm
definitely doing this after I create the
window because that's where of course we
create that data OpenGL contacts that we
did last episode so we'll go ahead and
type in GL Jenna vertex arrays we want
to Jen will generate one vertex array
and then put that into that that will
bind it
so we'll just bind Vettes right then
we're gonna do the same thing with our
veterans buffer so we'll go ahead and
generate a vertex buffer and bind it as
well so gel bind buffer chill array
buffer is the target type and then
vertex buffer all right and now we need
to actually populate it with some data
so we need to create some vertices so
I'll create this floor array called
vertices we'll say 3 times 3 so we're
gonna use 3 kind of three dimensional
coordinates and we're gonna have three
of them so three vertex positions over
here so we'll have negative 0.5 F
negative 0.5 F and 0.0 F so this is kind
of one vertex right it's a three
component vector basically it's like a
three dimensional like the three
dimensional coordinate in space now by
default if you don't have any kind of
projection matrix or you don't you
basically not transforming your vertices
by anything right you have kind of the
default clip space that OpenGL deals
with which is basically negative 1 to 1
in every axis so negative 1 to 1 X
negative 1 to 1 Y negative 1 to 1 z
that's kind of the rendering kind of
space that you're dealing with every
point eventually gets called convert it
to that obviously when you when you have
3d models there might be in some kind of
different scale completely different
space you might have vertices that you
know are 200 or something like that
right that's because it goes through
something called a projection matrix
which eventually cook like converts it
into negative one to one anyway since
we're not doing any kind of maths we
basically are in that space already
which is why the edges of the screen are
basically negative 1 to 1
ok so negative 0.5 is kind of a quarter
of the way from the left side of the
screen right and you'll kind of see this
one I actually draw the triangle so
we're gonna go counterclockwise right
hand to clockwise here without winding
because that's kind of default winding
so this is gonna be 0.5 FS is on the
other side of the screen we're kind of
drawing a few points if I start on paint
here I'm gonna show you this is kind of
percent of this white canvas is our
screen right essentially what we're
dealing with is three points that were
drawing we've just drawn one about here
right we're gonna draw one more here
that's the second kind of coordinate and
then we're gonna draw one here okay and
then obviously when we render it is
gonna kind of feel all of that in and
we're gonna get a triangle in the screen
okay
so this is 0.5 meaning that it's kind of
this is you know negative 0.5 I'm not
gonna pretend to kind of do this stuff
live for you guys but that's negative
0.5 X that's positive 0.5 X and that's
going to be 0 X right because right in
the middle and remember this is kind of
this edge is negative 1 and this edge is
positive 1 in the x-axis
same thing with y right this edge on the
bottom is negative 1 this edge is
positive 1 okay and then for Zed we're
leaving all of them just as 0 all right
0.5 or negative 0.5 would work as well
no difference sir will do 0.5 F will do
negative 0.5 of again because the Y of
course if that second point is the same
as the first one and then finally we'll
do a zero point zero F and then positive
0.5 F so this is kind of that topmost
point over here that we're rendering all
right sorry there we go now we need to
actually upload this data to the GPU
because obviously right now it exists in
the CPU so to do that
we'll just type in jail buffer data
again jail array buffer is kind of the
type of buffer that this is array buffer
vertex buffer basically just means it's
I don't know array buffer is an
interesting combination of words but
essentially just thinks about theis
buffer in this case just a buffer of
data size will be the size of vertices
this is this basically requires the size
of this data in bytes okay so you could
do size of 4 times 9 or whatever if you
want size of vertices will also give you
that same amount of bytes right that
same size because this is just a stack
array the actual data which is vertices
in the usage so for the usage will type
in GL static draw which basically just
means that we're not gonna be
continually like refreshing that array
with new data when I'm gonna continue
kind of uploading more and more data
every frame and kind of you know
replacing their data I mean we're not
gonna be streaming it or anything we're
gonna set this up once in the
constructor and that's kind of it so
it's static data okay cool and then the
last thing we need to do is actually
tell it in jail what the layout of this
buffer is cuz you know I mean it's great
that we can see that it's clearly three
different kind of Floyd kind of three
important flirt vectors right like three
back threes essentially OpenGL doesn't
know that it just sees it as a bunch of
bytes so we need to tell it what's up so
the first thing we'll do is GL enable
vertex a trip array which basically says
we're going to enable kind of index 0 of
our data you'll kind of see where this
goes in a minute and then vertex a trip
pointer I always forget this what is it
a trip no that's good like all right
this is chasing my open GL scale so
index 0 right so what kind of well
basically providing a vertex attribute
for the shader so that it can read this
data and we've basically enabled index 0
and what this is this is index 0 so
we're describing the data at index 0 so
there's 3 floats
essentially so we write 3 floats they're
not gonna be normalized
because of all that floats normalization
is for something else that we'll talk
about later the size here all sorry the
stride here is going to be basically the
amount of bytes between vertices so each
one of these is a vertex now clearly
we've just got a vertex position in this
case we've just got a position that's
our entire vertex so we just have three
floats three times four essentially
which is 12 bytes so we'll write three
times size of flirt
that's how stride so that's kind of the
amount of bytes between different like
vertices and then finally four it says
pointer we just put a null pointer in
this is essentially the offset of that
kind of attribute specifically now we
only have one attribute the offsets
always going to be zero basically that
just means that when I get to the next
vertex where does this attribute begin
it begins at by zero because we are
that's just the beginning of the vertex
that's all the data we have just the
position okay I think that's it so
that's all of that's what we have to do
for our kind of vertex buffer until
we've did we've basically created three
vertex positions and then to kind of
describe them to OpenGL as well as also
uploaded them to the GPU here all right
now we need to create that index buffer
so we'll do GL gen buffers let's see so
we'll generate it one index buffer will
do bind buffer now this time it's gonna
be element array buffer element array so
I call these index buffers really there
I guess technically if you were being
like old purist OpenGL you call them
element buffets not index buff is an
element buffer and an index buffer is
the same thing most people call them
index buffers in DirectX they're called
index buffers but you know every jail
called some element buffers I don't know
why they just wanted to be different or
whatever I'm not even sure the history
of this I'm not sure I'm not going to
say who like what's the correct way of
saying it but most of the industry
refers to them as in
that's why I call them as well it's what
I'm used to so we'll bind that buffer
basically it's just a buffer of like
vertex like it's a buffer of indices
which basically are indices are listed
second index into this vertex buffer so
it tells you kind of what order to kind
of draw these vertices in to fill this
triangle so clearly we kind of if we go
back to this for a second we clearly
kind of want to draw you know this one
first right and then this one second
and this one says so you can see kind of
it's like an index into array into an
array we kind of go over here we say we
want to draw this one first with index 0
then 1 then 2 right if we had another
triangle we keep going you can also
reuse vertices so if I had if I want to
draw a square and I wanted to have kind
of this was like the rest of my square
and this was index like 3 then
essentially what I could have is 0 1 2
to draw that triangle and then 0 1 3
except I probably do 0 3 1 because its
anti-clockwise to draw that ok and if I
kind of had those indices in my vertex
buffer I would only need these four
points but I could draw a square okay
because I can really use vertices but
more on that later so over here will
create unsigned and indices you can use
shorts or anything like that usually in
so pretty much the way to go either
because you'll probably never run out of
indices in that sense we'll have three
of them and that'll just be 0 1 2 ok
because we just have three points in our
triangle that's it
we'll do jail buffer data same thing as
we did with our batarangs buccal except
this time it'll be jail element array
buffer not that size is gonna be size of
indices dot is gonna be in C's and usage
again static girl all right sweet so
that's pretty much it I I'm just trying
to think if I've missed anything I don't
think so I mean we'll see if this works
and we'll debug it because of
only test to this but that should be
good so if we go down to what we
actually have to do every frame now
really all we have to do is bind that
vertex array which is and that is array
and then we just call GL draw elements
so again if called draw elements because
elements are our indices right so in
DirectX this is it would be called draw
indexed but in OpenGL cultural elements
because they call him to sees elements
all right so we have GL triangles is
armored kind of how we want to draw
these indices count how many we want to
draw three the type is gonna be jail
unsigned int and then the indices
there's a pointer to them we're gonna go
with null pointer the reason is we're
not providing an explicit index buffer
the one that is kind of attacked too
attached to our vertex array which
should be this one right because we have
the vertex array bound when we created
and bound this kind of index buffer that
X rays can retain that state so we
should be fine
so now if we just run this we should see
a triangle on the screen let's just see
what happens here all right check this
out so we have a triangle on the screen
that's pretty cool and as you kind of
saw what I kind of described and when I
drew in this little diagram of mine is
pretty much what you see on screen where
you know this is a kind of negative 0.5
positive 0.5 and positive zero as far as
X is concerned um and they you're
wonderful we've drawn our first triangle
and Hazel that's pretty exciting
now I didn't to mention that like we
don't actually need this bind vertex
right because clearly we've bound it
kind of here and we've left it bound but
I just wanted to be a little bit more
split it um yeah I mean hopefully this
made sense again you can see that we
don't need a shader it's just gonna give
us a white triangle by default contrary
to popular belief you're actually needed
shader to render stuff in modern OpenGL
and we are dealing with a corporate file
by the way and this should work with
pretty much all graphics drivers if it
doesn't let me know I don't have any AMD
hardware to actually test on but
I'm not sure if that that may be
problematic anyway
you obviously want to ideally delete
these things from the GP when you're
done with them and there's a lot you
know I mean this is not this is not
clear I would really ship but that's not
the point the point is just to draw a
triangle and hazel and then now you kind
of see what we need to do vertex arrays
need to be kind of moved into clinda
classes so does all this kind of buffer
we need to create an API out of this so
that we can do all this stuff in a
better way
Jen you know the index buffers as well
need to be moved into its own thing the
renderer would handle things like clear
color and the actual clearing although
you know clear and clear color things
that eventually would make themselves to
the actual render target or frame buffer
that you were actually using and then
draw elements again is something that
you do with the renderer so you tell the
renderer I am submitting this draw data
please draw it and then the renderer
itself would call field or elements to
actually draw that stuff so this is all
kind of stuff that eventually gets
abstracted out into its own classes but
now we have no everybody.you so that we
can actually begin doing that which is
pretty cool and and obviously we have
like a testbed of what we actually want
to do what I mean by that is like
instead of us just building classes then
at the end of it oh hey a triangle we
kind of have a triangle and we can work
backwards and I'm kind of a big fan of
that because getting stuff up and
running quickly is always a good thing
to see if it even works in the first
place and also it's just kind of more
motivating and just better to kind of be
like all of the triangle and also as we
do this over time you know what will
remove vertex race first for example
then buffer zone not sure which order
we'll do it in but suppose that was the
order we do it one step at a time and
then we keep checking and testing
it's our triangles still there oh no
it's gone clearly we've made a mistake
that's another very kind of good way to
actually work ok cool I wanted to do
something else yeah so I wanted to
actually show you guys how we can see
what graphics driver we have so if we go
into our OpenGL context class what I'm
actually going to do is when we've
actually made the context card and we've
initialized this stuff
I actually want to do GL I think it's
get string Jail bender
something like that I have to Google
this but essentially what this should do
is actually let us know and we'll do an
H set coy info or something this should
actually tell us you know I might say
OpenGL you know render up and this
should actually tell us what JB you were
using basically what drive are we're
using so if I just kind of run this card
maybe that will work again this is
completely off memory so if I'm wrong
I'm wrong but we'll see
where's that console here it is ok so it
just says OpenGL renderer Intel so it's
not that useful I'm not sure if there's
a better way to do that maybe by an
actual version number usually says kind
of what it is but I guess that's just a
vendor I've asked for let's see if
there's this gel renderer this shield
version so OpenGL renderer maybe I'll do
that and one sir let's see what this
does
I'll probably move this into it I'll
probably format this a bit nicer in a
second but I guess I want to see the
renderer as well
it's just raising that console window
okay so there we go Intel and then
internal HD graphics 530 okay cool this
looks pretty good
so what I'll do I'm just to clean this
up a little bit is all kind of to your
OpenGL renderer and then I'll probably
do H said core infer you know maybe like
two spaces and then venda and then we'll
kind of do a vendor render row and then
version okay just so that we get some
basic arc Angele kind of infer here so
we'll do a vendor over here we'll do
version down here shell version and then
you know render all Americas
open jail in fur or something like that
um okay cool and this is kind of just a
quick curd way of doing it but it should
give you pretty much everything you need
to know in just a really quick kind of
easy way so let's just run this again
Meli's compile times already look at
this there's all studios already kind of
that's because I've got that I'm
selected okay so there yeah okay
Jennifer so we have been the info
renderer and then version 4.4 awesome
okay so that's the kind of stuff that we
get with that and then what I can do and
what you guys probably should do is if
you go into your Nvidia control panel
you can just right click on your desktop
and then hit Nvidia control panel and if
you go to manage three settings then
program settings you can add that kind
of hazel thing here so I'll add that and
then I'll just make sure that it uses
the high performance and video processor
for example I'll hit apply on that and
then once that actually does apply if I
run it again it should actually use my
NVIDIA GPU instead so if I run this
again we go back to this you can see
that it now so now it says in a video
corporation we're using up reel 4.6
instead of 424 and you can see kind of
what card it's using as well okay so if
this does not work for you then now that
you have this extra code in your context
class just basically come over here and
just you know copy this and just paste
it in a comment and we'll see kind of
what drive as a problematic with this
but as far as I know this should be
pretty solid in kind of modern ish
hardware so maybe if you're using
hardware from ten years ago or something
but um I think that this kind of example
should work for most people
now I hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did you can hit that like button
you can also help support this series by
going over to patreon home for session
that sure note as I said in the
beginning of this video it's a really
great way to simple up a series I'm
super thankful to all the people who
actually do make this possible and yeah
like if you want kind of more advanced
car than this and you don't want to wait
wait to week that's the series cars then
a lot more stuff there cool this is
pretty exciting
our first triangle and hazel is now live
I will upload this code to github as I
do kind of at the end of every episode
so you can check it out and run it on
your computer and as I said it's kind of
see if it works
next time we're gonna kind of start well
there's two things that we could do next
time and since I'm not making an episode
early for patrons this week I just asked
you I can just ask you guys and see what
you want so we could either create a
shader and just out of shader to this
and make the triangle like a red or
something like that and kind of go
through how we're going to add a shader
to that or we can just start abstracting
this stuff out add a new shader would be
nice because it just means that we can
kind of have a full picture of what to
abstract and then we can do a lot more
kind of cool things I guess with that
but if you guys don't want to see that
if you guys would rather we get to the
abstraction faster and kind of just
create that renderer and build up that
rendering API as soon as we can then we
can also do that choice is yours I might
do a YouTube poll actually cuz that's
the thing right I'm not sure if it's
still a thing
I might either do that or just kind of
leave a comment below and just up for
comments that are saying the thing that
you want and you know I'll kind of read
them in a couple days and see what we
need to do all right
thanks for watching I'll see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]